Continue working on your project or open the file named 3-Assets, if you need to catch up.
In addition to ready-made materials, there are other asset types that you can pull from the Material Library.
Let's start by adding characters in the Theater area.
The process is simple. You go to that category in the Assets Library and then choose a sub-section.
You can work with posed humans, or better yet, animated characters among other types.
But before you start dragging additional assets into the scene, it's best to plan the scene management ahead.
You want to be able to control the visibility of certain elements independently from others.
In this case, go to the scene graph and collapse the opened theater and context containers.
Right-click the main scene graph entry and create a new container.
Name it Characters.
Next, right-click the newly created container and make it active.
This means that from this point on, any physical asset you add to the scene would be part of that container, making it easier to control.
Sure enough, add a character onto the stage. I will pick Camille in my case.
Note how she automatically snaps onto the surface, ensuring she's well-grounded in place.
If you want to place her elsewhere, use the yellow center of the Transform gizmo to snap her to a different surface.
Also note how she is part of the new active container in the scene graph.
This means you can control her visibility without affecting the rest of the scene.
You can make edits, of course, such as changing the color of her clothes or the kind of pose she is in.
Since she's on stage, I'll have her perform a little dance.
You can even pick a particular dance step from a few choices, and then fine-tune position and rotation if need be.
Similarly, you can add more characters to act as an audience.
It's just a question of choosing the right character and fine-tune the properties and the transforms to get them right.
Again, any new characters you add at this time will be part of the characters container.
Aside from individual characters, you can also choose from groups of characters.
They are essentially individual animated characters that were grouped together for easier manipulation.
The group itself can be repositioned but doesn't have any properties to edit.
The individual characters underneath, on the other hand, have the same properties you have already learned to adjust.
Similar to characters, you can add vehicles to the scene with a simple click and drag.
First, make sure you create a new active container named Vehicles, much like you did earlier for characters.
Go back to the root of the Assets library and choose the Vehicles subsection.
You have different types to choose from.
For now, experiment with a bus and a car.
Note that with cars, you can change the color after you place a car in the scene.
The process is simple enough, but if you would like to animate characters walking about or vehicles driving past,
then you can do that with Paths animation which we'll look at later.
Other assets you may find useful are Decals, which you can use to add markings and dirt spots over other surfaces.
They can be very useful for roads as you will see in a second.
Create a Decals active container. Consider that you can create a sub-container under a given section.
For example, you can create and activate a road decals container under Vehicles.
Go to the Objects section of the library.
Here, you'll find a collection of decals that you can use, including road markings.
Keep in mind that you cannot use a conventional scale transform on decals, but you do have scale properties that you can adjust.
You can select and duplicate decals as any other object using Shift-drag.
Using the Instance option, choose parameter changes on one item applied to all others.
Other types of useful decals allow you to add grunge or dirt onto surfaces.
Let's add a few stains on the asphalt.
If you want these stains to affect the road markings, then you may need to adjust the sort order.
As you can see, the library is quite extensive. Let's add some furniture to the cafe.
Again, create a new active container for the occasion, call it Props, and ensure it's active.
Go back one step to the Objects category and look into the Home section.
Look into the Living Room, Tables section.
Here we may find a few table types that we like.
Drag one of them into the scene.
You can add more of the same with additional drag and drop, or simply by duplicating the one you already inserted using Shift-drag.
Take a moment to add a few more props, like plants and wall decorations.
Again, if you mess up the positioning of an object, you can use the yellow center of the Transform gizmo to snap back the object onto any surface.
In addition to the native library, Twinmotion gives you full access to external libraries such as Quixel Megascans, Sketchfab, and even Adobe Substance 3D.
These can all be found at the root of the Asset Library.
Make sure you are signed in to your Epic account, and then you can download and place any asset from these external libraries.
I think I'll add a couple of boulders at the entrance of the cafe. The process is quite straightforward.
I still want to cover an important item, which is the User Library, which is one of my favorite features in Twinmotion and I'll do so in the next video.
But first, I will show you an interesting tool that lets you replace selected objects with another asset.
On the roof of the main building, you have several planters.
They look quite good, but let's assume you want to replace them with another planter from the Asset Library.
First, you select them in the viewport with the help of the Ctrl key.
Then you right-click on one of them in the scene graph and choose Replace Object.
Find the asset you want to use, in this case under Objects -> City -> Planters.
Drag the buxom planter into the Replace Object panel.
Make sure the Transform option is on, mostly to preserve rotations, and click the Start Replacement button.
And there you have it. Save your work. In the next video, you'll learn about the User Library.